>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
YOU THOUGHT YOU HAD A GREAT
WEEKEND.
SEE WHAT BARACK OBAMA DID?
IT WAS MORE FUN THAN ANYTHING
THAT HAPPENED AT YOUR HOUSE.
FOR HIS 60th BIRTHDAY, BARACK
OBAMA THREW A PARTY ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
HIS PLACE IS ON THE OCEAN
NATURALLY, BUT UNLIKE YOUR OCEAN
FRONT PROPERTY IN DESTIN,
OBAMA'S PROPERTY HAS BEEN
DECLARED EXEMPT IN THE RISE IN
SEA LEVELS THAT WILL OVERCOME
CRISIS IN CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
YOU CAUSED.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS, OBAMA
WILL BE SAFE ON MOR
ARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
EVER SENSITIVE TO THE FEELING OF
THE SUBJECTS, OBAMA DID HIS BEST
TO DOWN PLAY THE SIZE AND
OPULENCE OF THE EVENT.
HIS P.R. TEAM DID NOT MENTION
THE HUNDREDS OF SERVANTS.
THE PARTY WOULD BE NOTHING LIKE
KING FARUKE MIGHT HAVE HOSTED.
BARACK OBAMA'S PARTY WAS AN
INTIMATE GATHERING OF FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
IN THE END, THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
THE THING IS, YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE PHOTOGRAPHS, BARACK OBAMA
HAS A LOT OF VERY CLOSE FRIENDS.
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS WHO THEY
ARE.
JOE BIDEN WAS NOT AT THE PARTY
THAT IS WEIRD CONSIDERING THAT
JOE BIDEN AND BARACK OBAMA ARE
LIKE BROTHERS.
AS CLOSE AS TWO STRAIGHT MEN CAN
BE AS JOE BIDEN HAS TOLD US
HIMSELF MANY TIMES.
IF YOU HAD BEEN WATCHING
CAREFULLY, NOTICE THAT BARACK
OBAMA HAS NEVER MADE THAT CLAIM.
HE NEVER SAID A LOT ABOUT LIKING
JOE BIDEN.
NOW WE KNOW HE DOESN'T.
SO WHO DOES BARACK OBAMA LIKE?
WELL, IN A WORD, CELEBRITIES.
OBAMA LIKES CELEBRITIES.
LOTS AND LOTS OF CELEBTERTIES.
IT'S LIKE THE RED CARPET.
OPRAH, JAY Z, TOM HANKS, GEORGE
CLOONEY AND A BUNCH OF OTHER
PEOPLE YOU WOULDN'T RECOGNIZE IF
YOU DON'T LIVE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND OVER 30.
A TON OF THEM, A SURPRISE TO SEE
I.
BARACK OBAMA IS A GENIUS.
WE CAN BE CERTAIN OF IT BECAUSE
WE'VE HEARD THAT CLAIMED AS FACT
FOR 15 YEARS NOW.
YET WE KNOW THAT WHEN BARACK
OBAMA RELAXES AT HIS OWN HOUSE,
IT'S NOT WITH INTELLECTUALS OR
PEOPLE THAT CAN READ BOOKS, IT'S
WITH THE KIDS HE WATCHES ON TIK
TOK.
OBAMA PASSES AROUND HIGH FIVES,
THROWS ON SLIP-ON SHOES AND THE
ONLY GRAY HAWAIIAN SHIRT AND
HITS THE DANCE FLOOR.
IT'S PARTY TIME.
WAIT A SECOND, YOU ASKED, A GRAY
HAWAIIAN SHIRT?
IS THAT LEGAL?
WHEN YOU'RE BARACK OBAMA IT IS.
THE NORMAL RULES DON'T APPLY TO
YOU.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE MAN WHOSE
STAFF REFERRED TO HIM AS BLACK
JESUS WITHOUT SARCASM.
WHEN YOU'RE PART THE WAVES, YOU
DON'T GET HUNG UP ON FASHION
REGULATIONS OR PUBLIC
REGULATIONS.
THERE'S A GLOBAL PANDEMIC OUT
THERE.
MAY HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT.
IT'S GETTING WORSE.
THE CDC SAYS THE DELTA VARIANT
IS SO DANGEROUS THAT WE CAN NO
LONGER HAVE CIVIL LIBERTIES.
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS HAVE
BEEN SUSPENDED.
OUR CHILDREN HAVE TO WEAR MASKS
AL SCHOOL AGAIN.
WE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOW TO GO TO
DINNER, FLY ON AIRPLANES, HAVE A
JOB WITHOUT DISPLAYING OUR NEW
VACCINE PASSPORTS.
BARACK OBAMA SUPPORTS ALL OF
THAT.
HE'S FOR ALL THE RESTRICTION.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE WANTS TO
LIVE UNDER THOSE RESTRICTIONS.
SO ON SATURDAY, OBAMA'S GUESTS
DIDN'T HAVE TO SHOW THEIR PAPERS
TO GET INTO THE PARTY LIKE CNN
EMPLOYEES DIDN'T HAVE TO PROVE
THEY WERE VACCINATED.
UNLIKE YOUR KIDS, THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS.
IT'S LIKE 2019 AT THE OBAMA
HOUSE LIKE THE PANDEMIC NEVER
HAPPENED.
THE QUESTION IS, DOES TONY FAUCI
KNOW THIS?
IF SO, IS HE OKAY WITH IT?
THAT'S A PRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH
QUESTION.
WE CALLED TONY FAUCI TO FIND
OUT.
HE WAS TOO BUSY.
HE'S NOT INTO PUBLICITY.
HE WAS TIED UP DOING A PHOTO
SHOOT FOR "TEEN VOGUE."
OUR LOSS.
SO WE HAVE TO GO WITH HIS
PREVIOUS STATEMENT.
WHEN LARGE GROUPS OF MASKLESS
PEOPLE WITHOUT VACCINE PASSPORTS
GATHER IN ONE PLACE, IT'S A
GRAVE DANGER TO AMERICA.
BUT ONLY WHEN THOSE PEOPLE RIDE
HARLEY-DAVIDSONS.
SUNDAY FAUCI SCOLDED BIKERS
GATHERING IN STURGIS, SOUTH
DAKOTA.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DANGEROUS, TONY
FAUCI TOLD US.
SOME WENT TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND THERE'S SOME THAT DIDN'T GO
AT ALL.
YOU SHOULD BE WORRIED.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE TOLD US
LAST YEAR ABOUT THE STURGIS
RALLY THAT MANY WOULD DIE.
SO WE CHECKED BECAUSE NUMBERS
ARE IMPORTANT ON A NEWS SHOW.
DID THAT HAPPEN?
WHATEVER TO LAST YEAR'S STURGIS?
TURNED OUT ALMOST 500,000 PEOPLE
WENT.
450,000.
IN THE END, FEWER THAN 0.1% OF
THEM GOT COVID.
SO NO, MILLIONS DID NOT DIE.
IT WAS FINE.
TONY FAUCI DID NOT CHANGE HIS
GUIDANCE.
HE'S NOT DETERRED BY HIS OWN
BIGOTRY AND STUPID PREDICTIONS.
SO HERE HE WAS WARNING US A
AGAIN ABOUT THE PERILS OF
STURGIS.
>> WELL, I'M VERY CONCERNED,
CHUCK THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
ANOTHER SURGE RELATED TO THAT
RALLY.
I MEAN, TO ME, IT'S -- IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT PEOPLE WANT
TO DO THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY WANT THEIR FREEDOM TO DO
THAT.
THERE COMES A TIME WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THAT COULD INVOLVE YOU,
YOUR FAMILY AND EVERY UP WITH
ELSE THAT SOMETHING SUPERSEDES
THAT NEED TO DO WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO.
>> Tucker: WELL, I'M VERY
CONCERNED, CHUCK.
SO AS TONY FAUCI EXPLAINED,
GIVEN HOW DANGEROUS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH THOSE BIKERS AT STURGIS
ARE, YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER WHAT
THE RISK THE REST OF US FACE
MIGHT BE FROM BARACK OBAMA'S
MARTHA'S VINEYARD BIRTHDAY
PARTY.
HOW YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
INDOORS WITHOUT MASKS THAT
HAVEN'T PROVEN THEIR VACCINATION
STATUS.
IF THE NUMBERS TELL US ANYTHING,
QUIT A FEW OF THEM WERE NOT
VACCINATED.
IS THAT ACCEPTABLE OR NOT?
THAT'S AN URGENT PUBLIC HEALTH
QUESTION.
THE KIND THAT YOU THINK TONY
FAUCI EXISTS TO ANSWER AS THE
HIGHEST PAID PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEE.
HE DIDN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION.
AS WE TOLD YOU, WE TRIED AND HE
WON'T ANSWER IT.
SO WHERE DO YOU THINK BARACK
OBAMA GOT THE IDEA THAT IT'S A
GOOD IDEA TO HOLD A HUGE INDOOR
EVENT WITH PEOPLE THAT HAVE NOT
PROVEN THEY HAVE GOTTEN A SHOT
AND WITHOUT WEARING A MASK?
HOW CAN HE DETERMINE THAT?
MAYBE HE WATCHED HIS FRIEND,
MURAL BOWSER FROM D.C.
SHE DID THE SAME THING.
BOWSER YOU'LL RECALL FORCED A
NEW MASK MANDATE ON HER CITY BUT
DELAYED IT WITHIN HOURS LONG
ENOUGH TO HOLD A BIRTHDAY PARTY
FOR HERSELF.
THAT'S FINE.
IT'S COOL.
IT'S NOT LIKE SHE RIDES A
HARLEY.
SHE'S A DEMOCRATIC OFFICE
HOLDER.
NOW, IF YOU STILL BELIEVE IN
SCIENCE AND BECOMING SLIGHTLY
CONFUSED BY THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE, YOU DIDN'T WATCH CNN
THIS WEEKEND.
THEY LAID IT OUT.
LISTEN TO THIS REPORTER FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EXPLAIN WHY
BARACK OBAMA CAN HAVE MASKLESS
PARTIES INDOORS WITHOUT VACCINE
PASSPORTS AT THE SAME TIME THAT
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO VISIT YOUR
DYING PARENTS IN THE HOSPITAL.
IT'S NOT ARBITRARY.
THERE'S A REASON, A MEDICAL
REASON.
WATCH.
>> OTHER PEOPLE SAID, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS REALLY BEING OVERBLOWN.
THEY'RE FOLLOWING ALL THE SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SPORTING
EVENTS BIGGER THAN THIS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SAFE, THIS
IS A SOPHISTICATED VACCINATED
CROWD.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
NOW WE'RE TALKING SCIENCE.
WHEN IT HAPPENS AT BARACK
OBAMA'S 12 -- OVER $20 MILLION
HOUSE ON THE OCEAN THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE, WHEN IT HAPPENS THERE,
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
THE CROWD -- WE'RE QUOTING "NEW
YORK TIMES" -- IS SOPHISTICATED
AND VACCINATED.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
VACCINATED BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO PROVE IT.
AGAIN, IF THE NUMBERS ARE RIGHT,
A LOT OF THEM WEREN'T
VACCINATED.
MAYBE MORE THAN HALF.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE WAS
SAYING.
THE EMPHASIS HERE, THE MEDICALLY
SIGNIFICANT WORD IS
SOPHISTICATED.
RIGHT NOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FORCING
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE TO OBEY
EVERY REQUIREMENT THAT
VACCINATED PEOPLE HAVE TO
FOLLOW.
IT'S THE SOPHISTICATED CROWDS
THAT ARE EXCEPT FROM THE RULES.
YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW THE
SOPHISTICATED IN THIS COUNTRY,
THE KING FARUKES THAT WALK AMONG
US ARE ALSO EXEMPT FROM HAVING
TO PAY TAXES.
EXEMPT FROM HAVING THEIR POLICE
DEFUNDED.
EXEMPT FROM HAVING CATHOLIC
CHARITIES MOVE PENNILESS
IMMIGRANTS INTO THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE NEW SECTION
8 HOUSING ON YOUR STREET.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
SOPHISTICATED.
IT'S NICE TO BE SOPHISTICATED.
IT'S BAD TO BE UNSOPHISTICATED.
IF YOU'RE UNSOPHISTICATED, CNN
WON'T COME TO YOUR DEFENSE.
ITS ANCHORS WON'T DEFEND YOU.
WHEN YOU'RE UNSOPHISTICATED,
THEY WILL DEVOUT HOURS TO
MOCKING YOU.
>> YOU THINK THIS WILL BE A
SUPER SPREADER EVENT?
>> I'M SURE.
THE SLOGAN FOR STURGIS, WE'RE
SPREADING OUR WINGS BUT I'M
CONCERNED THEY WILL SPREAD MORE
THAN THEIR WINGS.
>> FEW ATTENDEES WORE MASKS LAST
YEAR.
THAT'S LIKELY TO BE THE CASE
AGAIN THIS YEAR.
>> THIS YEAR STURGIS RALLY
ATTENDEES PROVED THEY DIDN'T
LEARN ANYTHING.
DRAWING A BIGGER CROWD AMID A
SURGE OF CASES CAUSED BY THE
DELTA VARIANT AND THE
UNVACCINATED.
>> ANNUAL EVENT KICKED OFF OVER
THE WEEKEND WITH PACKED BARS,
ROCK CONCERTS AND BARELY ANY
MASKS.
>> YOU THINK THEY'D LEARN.
BUT NOPE.
>> YOU'D THINK THEY LEARN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE RIDING A
MOTORCYCLE OUTSIDE WITH NO MASK
ON.
RECKLESS FREAKS KILLING THE REST
OF US.
YOU'D THINK THEY WOULD LEARN!
NOPE?
THAT'S THE JUDGMENT OF DR. DON
LEMON.
THERE WAS NO COVID OUTBREAK AT
STURGIS LAST YEAR.
SOMEHOW NOBODY HAS TOLD CABLE
NEWS.
THEY'RE CONVINCED IT WAS A SUPER
SPREADER EVENT GO TO CNN'S
WEBSITE AND YOU'LL FIND A PIECE
WITH THIS HEADLINE.
"SOUTH DAKOTA STURGIS MOTORCYCLE
RALLY A CAUTIONARY TALE IN THE
AGE OF COVID-19."
A CAUTIONARY TALE!
CAUTION AGAINST WHAT?
BELIEVING DUMMIES AT CNN?
IN THE PIECE CNN REPORTS WITH
HORROR THAT THERE ARE VIRTUALLY
NO TIK TOK STARS THIS YEAR AT
STURGIS.
THEY'RE ALL AT MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
OPRAH HAS NEVER BEEN TO STURGIS.
ACCORDING TO CNN, STURGIS
INVOLVES DRAG RACES, ROCK
CONCERTS, TATTOO CONTESTS, PUB
CRAWLS AND PROCESSIONS OF
HARLEY-DAVIDSONS THROUGH THE
BLACK HILLS MOUNTAIN RANGE.
WHOA!
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, RIGHT?
PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER.
OR AGAIN IN THE WORDS OF CNN,
THE STURGIS RALLY HAD MANY
CHARACTERISTICS OF A SUPER
SPREADING EVENT.
LARGE CROWDS, HIGH INTENSITY OF
CONTACT BETWEEN PEOPLE,
POTENTIAL FOR HIGHLY INFECTIOUS
INDIVIDUALS TRAVELLING FROM HOT
SPOTS AND EVENTS IN POORLY
INVENTED LATED INDOOR
ENVIRONMENTS.
NOT AT ALL LIKE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING UNDER THE TENT IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WITH THE TIK TOK KIDS.
TURNS OUT THEY'RE KNO